okay 32 a no at 16 knockouts as a
prizefighter undefeated boxing champion
and about to reprise his role of Danny
stuntman wheeler in Creed - the host of
epochs is the contender which has a
finale to our special episode at 10:00
p.m. Eastern on epics on Friday night at
the Forum good to see you Andre Ward I
finally made it I'm on the Rich Eisen
show they said I'm happy all those belts
the titles Creed acting with Michael B
Jordan that's the sporting world like
I'm in a different space now
broadcasting analysts work to be here
being in that space I've made it really
I will take that
so are you say you're a contender for
this seat I wouldn't say that okay
you're you're a wily veteran I'm just
learning to take your notes I'm loving
it
I missed the sport I get that out the
way I miss it I mean you get in the ring
I mean that's part is that part of what
you like about this I mean you get in a
little bit not really like that wasn't
the plan okay that was not the plan I
did not bring like workout stuff and
like but the Freddie Roach he's so
unassuming but somehow someway
he talks me into getting out of the
street clothes and getting my workout
gear on and getting in there with his
guys he's like Andre come here you know
I got a couple guys I need a few runs
I'm like Freddie yeah I was just coming
to watch just maybe four or five rounds
my friend next thing you know I'm in
there spawning you see the clip that you
just yeah we just saw that right there
well that's Freddie Roach man I mean
Freddie's Freddie's and he's a goat
right Freddie Freddie is Freddie Roach
so let me get into it then it's been 16
months since you retired
is there any hitch at all to unretire I
know that it's word gets thrown around
it's not a niche but it's more just like
you just miss it you know like you miss
it you miss having a fight on the
horizon and you miss believe it or not
the process you know being away from
your family being in training camp
around your guys your strength coach or
head coach
and just you know fighting for a goal
like trying to reach some you know reach
a pinnacle
and beat the goddess across from you and
the checks I you know those weren't bad
guys about to say I mean you've seen
some of the checks like Canelo getting
right now those aren't bad either so
let's just say this we're seeing what
happen with triple G and Canelo they'd
have to come up and wait to fight you
what if something like that was thrown
in your way I hope it doesn't like I
hope that because it's too tempting I
just hope it's serious Kara isn't dangle
because I don't even want to have to go
through the process of thinking and
mulling and I just just let just let me
be let me kind of ride off in the sunset
but there is a small party that wants
the phone call but but more of me
doesn't because I don't want to have to
go through that process you've missed it
I do and I'll probably always miss it
but that doesn't mean that I should be
in a boxing ring and I think that's
that's the struggle that's the fine line
that that guys have to try to find just
because you miss it and just because you
can still do it doesn't mean you should
I mean we just are now obviously
completely different endeavors I mean
Cormier is pushing 40 okay
that's my boy and I'd love that guy I
love DC he's pushing 40 and still doing
it you're 34 yeah I mean you're much
younger man am I about trying to squirm
a little bit you know you're 34 and so
somebody comes in and throws that in
front of you you know triple G's older
than you he's uh we had an opportunity
to fight well yes
when was this this was prop takes
somewhere around 2012 2013 somewhere
around there I was in the midst of a
lawsuit but I could still fight and long
story short I had heard him say that hey
he fought at 160 pounds he said listen
I'll fight anybody from 160 to 175 well
that's my weight class I'm 168 hmm
had my team reach out and they pretty
much turned it down in less than five
minutes they said hey we're going a
different direction if these guys meet
up to the road so be it but we're not
interested right now and that's fine
like I'm not a guy that's like trying to
fight smaller guys but you mentioned my
weight class and you said that you'd be
willing to fight any of the champions
we'll hear
he just didn't wanted here you are I'm
sick I'm I'm seeing there's some there
there I'm saying there's something there
there
he's already entertained the idea of
fighting you he'll never fight me not
now I guarantee he'll never you
he never in the only way he was ever
gonna get in the ring with me was if he
had no choice he's all he always has a
choice but if if the fans start to
demand it and clamor for it which they
they did but not to the degree that you
know that will put him in a position
where he just kind of had to give in
that's the only way he was gonna be able
to do get in the ring with me other than
that he'd look for the side door the
back door every time if I wasn't
somebody who's looking you in the face
Andre Ward and seeing what you you look
like and know that you're saying what
you mean and mean what you say I would
say that this is the sort of rhetoric
that's normally thrown out there to get
a fight that's what I would say I would
say this I'm happy in retirement I wish
him nothing but the best and I honestly
hope the phone doesn't ring with the
serious care I'll just say that so
please don't call in the meantime let's
talk about Brandon Adams versus Shane
Mosley yes which is the finale of The
Contender on Epic's it's coming up
Friday at the Forum 10 p.m. Eastern Time
two-hour special episodes streaming live
on Twitter and Epix what about this
fight fired up that's the name that a
lot of people would recognize right yes
Shane Mosley jr. Shane Mosley believe it
or not with the name was still a bit of
an eye ball his careers kind of been up
and down up until this point he's always
had the talent ability skill he comes
from great seed obviously his father's a
legend Shane Mosley senior but he never
put it all together at the right time so
nobody knew what he was gonna how he was
gonna fare on the show he showed himself
very very well he showed that he had the
ability which we all knew but he showed
the mental capacity and Nazim Richardson
the other legendary trainer that was a
part of this show had a lot to do with
that because he stayed on Shane and he
knows how to push those certain buttons
he knows how to motivate them and when
the guys in the house started to pick on
Shane or leave
tried to pick on Shayne and tried to
bait Shane Nazim was always you know in
earshot saying man he called him soldier
so soldier don't get involved with that
stay focused you're here to do this
you're here to do that and Shane
responded you know very very well that's
why he's in the finals is he many sugars
eat sugar Junior
what does he like to call him Splenda
I think nah same calls him sugar and
spice she's something like that okay
yeah and he likes to call himself sugar
man okay that's that's Shane's name for
himself to basically say yes I'm a part
of my dad's legacy but I'm a man now so
sugar man nutrasweet or no just free to
work listen you can fight I'm only
seeing these things cuz he's not in the
room Brandon Adams versus Shane Mosley
jr. the finale on on The Contender on
ethics again Friday night at the forum
good stuff 10:00 p.m. Eastern on epics
retiring undefeated what does that mean
who fighter obviously Floyd's undefeated
he's still at it it seems really indeed
really retired like whoo I don't know
what's going I don't know what do you
think's going on I don't know i money i
think money's garin's yes big carrots
and does he need the couch I can't say
if he needs them but I feel like we all
know that I mean if you're if your
mantra if your moniker is money that's
what it's all right maybe he does need
the carrots if he bet the Cowboys on
Monday Night Football
could mean that we never see his losing
ticket you'd never do MMA would you know
that's crazy wherever like like we're in
the the tidies mmm with no socks and
like that's weird
I think there's six ounce gloves and oh
it's about to shake the fashion thing is
it just likes a little bit of both the
fashion thing it's the it's the craft
like in in UFC I don't really like pay
like boxing they've kind of got a set
you know that's what kind that's what
Conor stepped in the square ring right
yeah but I mean Connors kind of
transcended things you know with the
fanbase that he brings so he's probably
getting more than most but they don't I
was shocked I thought it was a typo when
I actually did some digging and figured
out that man these guys are making six
figures right and they're putting thirty
thousand twenty thousand people in the
seat selling you know two million
pay-per-views 1.5 million pay-per-views
that's just their pay structure so it's
the last a lot of reasons why I wouldn't
jump in octagon you wouldn't jump in the
yeah well it's great to see you Andre I
know you got a lot going on your your
honor your you've got other stuff to do
today I'd love to sit here and chat much
more with you certainly if you view this
as a stepping up stepping stone to
appear on this program I'm taking notes
I'll take it now watch what it what did
I what did you learn from the ease in
which you present yourself like I know
you have you have a lot of notes on your
dad's got a ton of notes it's not very
they're all over the place right now
you've highlighted several things so
there's key points you're trying to make
this is like controlled chaos
television radio podcast you know that
but you act like you still walking apart
well I'm just talking to you so I'm
trying to get there well you are you are
here I mean you're you're you seem to be
nice and relaxed you've done a very good
job of promoting the place you did I got
a good poker face you know and let's
just put it this will help I'll leave
you with this if you get that phone call
with that carrot that's dangled and you
grab that carrot and you just you eat it
oh I just want a little cut a little
piece a little taste wet my beak a
little bit Andre because what you
started today like this would probably
have a lot to do with this this would be
the origin of the carrot coming the fact
that you kind of put it out there the
way you did today
so I think that's fair okay you getting
to cut this getting a little I mean
we'll have my people talk to you we'll
get it done okay but it's a it's a big
if okay well if you come back down from
you from the Bay Area right yeah norther
okay in really California you get out of
there you're warriors bubble up there
they come back down here let's chat some
more I would love it okay that would be
great and then the big if I can't wait
and by the way Creed to congratulations
on that excited about it Thanksgiving
weekend Thanksgiving weekend what's that
what was that like shooting with
greeting cream loved a challenge great
stuff I got bit by the bug I got bit by
the bug
so that's a carrot that that is a
legitimate carrot that is that is a
tangible legitimate yes
I'm excited about Crete I'm excited
about hopefully doing more acting in the
future okay
then in the meantime check out again the
contender on FX Friday night at the
Forum Brandon Adams versus Shane Mosley
jr. Friday 10:00 p.m. Eastern good to
see you sir come back any time this is a
delight Andre Ward right here on the
Rich Eisen show the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience